Mark LG already uh sneaking some break
and he's at their Jeremy boring put in
the contract that Stephen had to stop
wearing women's clothes that's true I
didn't know that there's a lot of stuff
that's coming out so fast
that was the deal that was the deal
breaker
so all you young creators out there
don't sign this don't sign these things
okay let's say you can't wear sexy uh
pantyhose that's a slave contract so the
the the the seat the the CEO of the
daily wire uh Jeremy Jeremy fitting name
yeah the most fitting name ever Jeremy
boring
um yeah so we covered this yesterday and
there's a clip on the clip Channel ROTC
clip Channel on YouTube but
um we we covered this yesterday uh
Crowder and the big con thing if you
want to see our [__] take on that
well then you should have paid all right
I'll just tell you yeah it's on the
locals but there is clip there's a clip
of it also on the clip channel so if you
want to get our take on that basically
it breaks down to Crowder only cares
gets affecting him now
as predicted
um I predicted this yesterday because
daily wire never ran a story on it it
was daily wire and I'm not pretending I
was a [__] genius a bunch of people
like it's the daily water because
there's not a lot of if you think about
there's not a lot of options like so two
or three people that could do it right
with that kind of yeah with that kind of
pull and that kind of money right so the
contract was for and we're gonna play a
little bit here
um I had so many people last but last uh
when I was covering that thing asking me
like is it Rumble what about raw and I'm
like I'm like no like we have we have
our thing with Rumble and like we own
everything they all they wanted was hey
just don't go anywhere else just use our
platform we can tell you that it's not a
rumble it's not a rumble contract I can
tell you as soon as I saw you don't own
the thing we control I'm like I ain't
the way it is and also because it was
[__] it wasn't 500 pages like a daily
wire one either you know
um so I can tell you that right now he's
really smart because he has books on his
table anyway and also we knew it was
daily wire because the contract reads
like Ben Shapiro talks yeah okay so
that's a million dollars every time you
miss work
so now the contract was for 50 million
dollars with a possibility of a one-year
extension for 25 million dollars with 75
million dollar contract
now Crowder of course is one of my
favorite people when he's bitching about
a contract considering he makes all his
employees site ndas and now knowing how
much money that he was offered or he's
making or that he could easily turn down
because he could make that or somewhere
else
why were you severely underpaying your
employees like not K Jared and Sven
computer why were you why were you
paying him so little I don't understand
yes because he's a greedy uh
Psychopathic piece of [__] right so
um he uh boring did this so let's let's
check let's see what Matt Walsh's dad
has to say okay
our friend Stephen Crowder has launched
a new initiative called stop big con and
in the video announcing the launch of
the project he talked about leaving the
Blaze and all by the way it's really
hard to act I know that this is an
Optics thing and I'm not saying this so
you should judge people but it's really
hard to act like you're not big con when
what's behind you looks like the [__]
Daily Planet from Superman really does
it looks like the vice offices when Vice
was making money yeah
a lot of Brooklyn [__] when they had
that whole Loft and everybody's like
look we're just a small we're just a
small Network in the back East here give
me pictures of Superman yeah it's like
what's it yeah look we are a small
Independent Media brand that makes
million dollar movies yeah officers from
other conservative organizations and
what he thought were the real problems
with those offers and that's led a lot
of people to speculate about whether or
not the daily wire is one of the people
who made him an offer in particular are
we the ones who made the offer uh that
he put up on the screen and talked about
um at length and the answer is yes that
offer did come from the daily wire I'm
not trying to hide that fact I'm not
ashamed of that fact in fact I think
it's a very good offer but I think
there's a lot of
sort of misconceptions about the nature
of the offer the nature of the points I
think Stephen misunderstood a lot of the
points and so the way we I don't think
he misunderstood it see now you're going
to put me in a weird position where I'm
going to defend Stephen Crowder here I
don't think you misunderstood it we read
them
everybody didn't misunderstand but this
is his way of being polite
because I'm sure that I'm sure what they
really want to do is be like this
[__] but instead it's like I I
you know what it's the polite way of
going I think my friend is just mistaken
yeah you know what I mean we try not to
start world war three right now you do
here at the daily wire we're just gonna
be incredibly transparent you know that
we
like to have our members be a part of
the journey we live stream all of our
company town halls for example we just
find that Journey
his last name is boring virgin yeah
sometimes is the best disinfectant and
so with that in mind I'm going to talk
to you a little bit about how we came to
be in conversations with Stephen
um how those conversations ended and
entire 52-minute video him talking there
is a 52-minute response to a 25 minute
video
they've had it with him
I was so excited about this I was I
literally I lit a cigarette in my studio
last night I was so happy I was like oh
my god let's pour drinks this is amazing
the snake is eating itself yes
it says we'll have the exclusive right
to realize Revenue in connection with
all of his content and brand we're
paying you this guaranteed
significant amount of money 50 million
dollars and for that one of the things
we're buying is the content but we're
also buying the right to monetize the
content so that we can have a chance of
making some money and not just spending
money
Crowder's doing it for selfish reasons
but this is a [__] shitty contract
there's not and I don't care who these
[__] people are you cannot tell me
that listen
should have cried or what would I
Crowder should have done was counter
offer
Crowder crying because he's not getting
the deal that he wants is gay just don't
sign the deal that's the way I look at
it yeah don't make a [__] Crusade out
of it that's [__] gay as [__] but
that being said this is a pretty shitty
contract on top I mean is it though when
it's 192 days a year it's I looked it up
dude it's 6.3 months of work for 50
million dollars is it that bad I mean I
guess it really depends well I guess it
really depends on whether you want to
keep 100 creative control of your
product or don't and I look that being
said for 50 million dollars I'd probably
sign the deal let me be clear with you
here I'm not going to sit here and
pretend like I wouldn't but what I am
saying is is that
if you take the money amount out of it
it's a shitty contract
for like somebody that's not crowd or
first you know the the of course yeah
but but then again the person that's not
Crowder ain't Crowder you can't command
that kind of money and I'm sure the
penalties aren't as big when you're not
getting paid as much the penalties are
really big in this contract because The
Upfront money is really big so I mean
I'm not defending daily wire here but 50
million dollars to work [__] to work
for 4.3 or 6.3 months out of the year
yeah [__] out of here you can't handle
that Steve
I mean it's a first draft [__]
contract okay there are places where
this language should be added to it but
I mean for as far as the losing rights
to monetization and [__] that's just
basic [__] like record deal [__]
about your garbage contracts but that's
that's pretty standard in entertainment
I'm not listen I'm not in any way first
off what Crowder's doing and he's doing
it for attention what this means to me
is that Crowder on his own can make more
than 50 million dollars now we know and
this is just him pushing his humongous
email list Crowder's email you know what
Crowder's value is
is real value and I'm not talking about
his net worth or all that stuff oh like
what is the source of his value his
email list is is it's specifically his
MailChimp I hope he's not using that but
his email list is what is his worth is
that's what it is it's the same way like
if you're if you ever see like an HVAC
company or a plumbing company go under
oh you have other smaller companies just
fly in not to buy the company or to buy
anything but to buy the call the
customers oh the yeah that's that's
that's Crowder's money there okay have
you been to stop bigcon.com yeah yeah we
went we went live yesterday yeah okay
yeah it's just it's just enter your
email
it's a Mud Club to mug Club portal yeah
what is the content
first we broke this into daily monthly
quarterly and annual content the daily
content is going to be very obvious to
you he'll deliver a one and a half hour
louder with Crowder audio video show of
a quality and kind one and a half hours
190 100 yeah 192 days a year [__] me I'd
also like to point out that at no point
do they State he has to be live and Mr
boring here actually points out he could
have had more days off on top of his
regular four weeks off he says he's
pre-taped he said he does already yeah
he basically said that uh like if he had
to go do a gig or whatever then all you
had to do was let them know and
pre-record another episode just bang out
a two for one day on a Thursday and
leave
like so that they have a show lined up
to premiere for him
he could literally this was not really
this was not that brutal of a contract
Grace you want me to really piss you off
all right so let's say let's say for
three months he just does two shows a
day [__] me he only has to work three
months out of the year he could take the
rest of it off
it's nice right
50 mil 25 million uh after the contract
if uh everything goes well huh 75 mil to
not be funny for a living do not be
funny for only 192 days a year
50 million dollars but can I still wear
dresses yes
you know I just still I don't I I don't
this doesn't feel right
um hey before the show Virgie you asked
me the question and the answer is rock
and roll all night how can we do a
parody of that because that's the way
you make money
parodies famous songs
and should we just become hacks
well I mean we're having there now
should we become like this level of hack
all right so We Do Katy Perry's Roar but
instead of Eye of the Tiger we say I've
got the jab of the Pfizer huh
he's getting too good let's not gay
Jared him my heart rate is good hey
how'd you like to sign a restricted Ida
and then make eight dollars an hour how
does that sound why does this NDA say
anal allotted and also why is my
microphone unplugged like the little
brothers on the NES and the best part is
this little piece of [__] he's foreign
so we could also use his visa and hover
that over him oh my gosh that is
genius so you're like you're like okay
Jared computer all rolled into one yeah
the whole thing was Jared was gay right
that's beautiful though and then you're
50 Jared you're 50 Sven computer this is
great and then Virgie and then and
Virgie Who's Live who who will call
lives like a quarter black is actually
this is perfect that's just one thing I
hate more than being called racist it's
letting down a friend yeah all right
hashtag goblet gang order your revenge
of the sis Goblin
I like pimp chalices
there's just some [__] [__] up gold
plastic cup and a bunch of rhinestones
loose in the Box yes exactly they fell
off
Frozen and here's the thing Frozen she's
falling off get Amy Staley to make you
[__] some kind of laser engraved [__]
right she does all that and we'll have
Frozen be our Asian lawyer even though
he doesn't know law they'll just think
he's alive we just sent him very
ill-prepared into court all the time
yeah he's always constantly shuffling
I'm really sorry sending me here and I
keep telling him I'm not alone I'm a
chef I don't know what I'm doing here we
maybe no numbers Frozen has to wear a
big he has to wear big hands like
Charlie's Uncle don't laugh don't look
no look don't look look daily wire will
have the exclusive rights to sell ads on
the Crowder content on all platforms
websites apps and they'll own the Riff
oh God
hey Royce yeah all of all of his live
reads are pre-recorded he just he does
one live read every like four years oh
my God
yeah I love that they call them live
reads when everybody nowadays they just
do one more different clothes different
shoes and hats and shirts when they do
the live reads they can they just bump
one out and they just put it yeah you're
watching real ass podcasts and Lewis and
Zach are sitting there then they go to
live reads and [__] Lewis and figs
are sitting there and you're like wait a
minute hold on a moment hey hey doggy I
want to tell you about your Kratom like
you [__] you're just you're just banging
these out and alive when his legs in the
cast and the library's legs fine yeah
he's doing jumping jacks
it's like all right guys uh we're gonna
be right back after this uh we'll do our
plugs and then it just cuts through hey
hey doggy
you know what I like more than running a
media Empire boners that's just really
awesome
um
you ever [__] on kratom
y DW will own all the contact can't [__]
off Ralph's walking around in the
background he looks three years younger
yeah how long ago did you do this
Library
Pacific 30w a daily wire can exploit
those channels Brands and content and
perpetuity at its sole discretion
created here in and will own all of the
DW created channels and Brands created
by US during the term yeah Jeremy Jeremy
from the quartering now is [__] just
totally trying to like he's just
Crowders water because he's his buddy
okay so you you skipped past it just now
but underneath of the thing he just read
was something way worse that I was
reading uh look look for adaption
uh adaption rights
daily wire will have the right to adapt
and monetize anything Crowder says or
writes on his podcast
social media Etc both daily wire owning
Crowder's personal channels books or
media hits for daily wire articles for
free or subscription marketing and
promotion social media post merch or
newsletters and no additional approval
required from Crowder so they could
basically take over his Twitter account
and use it if they want to yeah without
giving it is that worth 50 million
dollars yeah if you if that was in your
contract Rumble would have revenge of
the sauce out [__] by Tuesday dude
dude if that was my contract if they
were like pessy we need to we get to do
whatever we want on your Twitter you
know what I do I'd be like okay cool I
changed my Twitter to the midnight Rift
party Twitter and then make another
Twitter for personal [__] no because it
even covers Crowder's personal stuff too
it says it oh does it really yeah how
much how much did they offer both and
Crowder's personal checks okay though 50
million dollars I mean no no I
understand what you're saying that's a
cartoon amount of money but don't let
Crowder's trying to sell this to you
like I'm now crowd I haven't seen it yet
but I'm assuming Crowders retort this is
gonna be like yeah it was 15 million
dollars and I walked away because I'm so
virtuous that I walked away from 50
million that's going to be the reply but
that's not the real reason why Crowder
wants 50 million dollars and to give up
nothing that's the reality of what he
wants and don't get me wrong that does
sound like a sweet deal I do understand
daily wireside that they need to make
money off of him right right but that
being said don't act like you're not
going to make money just by having
Crowder on the [__] Channel because
he brings the thing is I'm wondering if
Crowder was worried about that they were
going to get his mailing list
yeah I'm sure that's that's the biggest
thing because that's what's worth money
is his mailing list
you know get people to sign up for daily
wire Plus
but now there's a lot of people that I'm
seeing on to be like [__] daily wires
piece of [__] and they are a piece of
[__] and they [__] suck but in the
same breath saying how awesome Crowder
is and there's the other side of people
that are ripping on crowder defending
daily wire and I'm like both both sides
are kids they're both terrible
both sides are awful here they all
[__] suck although you are part of
the same [__] [__] mechanisms
okay
stop none of you are [__] fighting
for anybody other than 50 million
dollars stop it okay his Boomer list
exactly his [__] Boomer email lists
that are probably all at Yahoo and at
AOL
it's so [__] it's funny watching uh
the quartering now he's front lashing
and he's like oh all the penalties in
his contract added up to 110 and then
like there's even people now they're
like lawyers that are responding and
going like no [__] because literally
if a contract drops below a certain
amount it's null and void anyway yeah
they can't take more from you at the end
of a contract like that's just not any
[__] Court in the world would have
tore that thing up if they were that
brutal about it I I understand again the
stipulations were [__] but if I'm
paying you 50 mil and I'm only asking
you to work 192 [__] days I am
putting Clauses in that contract that
says hey [__] that annual event
that we're gonna pump money into you're
gonna show up for that [__] thing or
we're penalizing you they didn't get
into it because the video is so goddamn
long and I hope somebody cuts up a super
cut
um he also basically said that the the
annual events that he was talking about
those were going to be like when they go
to like Texas a a m and it's a big daily
wire like uh you know it's like several
personalities and it's a big event and
he probably would have first of all
probably gonna make money off that live
event there's no way they're just not
paying for showing up and basically the
contract was like yeah if we if we sink
like you know three quarters of a
million dollars into an event and you
know show it we're gonna tax you bro
we're only asking to work 192 days a
year now I will agree the social media
[__] and all that little uh all that
little [__] is where I start to be like
no you're not going to Tweet for me and
what do you personal things too so what
are you gonna go through my DMs I was
just gonna say you're gonna go through
my diary and [__] use that in your
[__] daily wire articles [__] out of
here I literally literally though the
way that it was worded if if Stephen
Crowder had a diary they could publish
it and he wouldn't have any that's what
I'm saying it's [__] hilarious tall
and nasty said if Crowder would just
would this is actually 100 true as an
example if Crowder was just to use
locals right if if all of of his 350 000
Mud Club subscribers just 350 000 okay
uh and he just he just went to logos
with the five dollar subscription rate
okay he would make just two million
dollars a month so 50 million over four
years ain't nothing to how much money he
has just because of his mailing list and
that's true
um not saying that all hundred and three
hundred and fifty thousand of them were
gonna sign up but even if you have to
let's say you get a million a million
over four years I mean really then you
keep you you make of the same amount and
you keep a hundred percent of your
content so Crowder is please by no means
think that Crowder is walking away from
50 million dollars like Dave Chappelle
did it because this is like if Dave
Chappelle walked away from 50 million
dollars to get a 60 million dollar deal
from HBO the next day that wouldn't be
virtuous that just be taking a better
deal that's what Crowder is doing and
that whole like maybe it's time for me
to walk away maybe I have to it's all
[__] [__] please do not fall for
it do not fall for his [__] act it's
all a [__] act and only because we've
been doing this for so long how many
times have we seen this thing every year
once a year it's the Crowder is going to
say they want to take my show down sign
up to my mug Club Festival so I mean is
this what we have to do do we just have
to be fake and gay
you already said [__] I'm telling you
I already said smoking in the non-gender
binary room that's a great [__] title
right there
and everybody knows the tampons are
allowed in boys rooms boom I there we go
baby I don't want to live like this
let's go
let's go Crowder clip please don't just
just for the title just for the title I
would be trying like if I got locked
into that contract and had to act like
Crowder for a year and do song parodies
and [__] you know I would [__] snap I
would snap down in the gender neutral
bathroom peeing sitting down in the
gender people just be asking Royce how's
marshmall he's been trying to get fired
every day he literally he hurled a chair
across the daily wire offices the other
day he really wants out of this [__]
yeah sharp out of the office like a
prison okay I'm not gonna I had to pull
him off of a [__] cameraman the other
day while we were filming a [__]
Queen parody
the title of this video is that I'm not
gonna play it but just because it's a
funny title thank you Virgie delusional
Colin Kaepernick Compares slavery to
million dollar contracts 50 million
dollar contract router
it's slave contracts
I'm one I'm wondering if um
Crowder did this he was always going to
say no I'll be a slave for 50 million
because I wish I was Stephen Crowder I
wish I was Steven Crowder
um hold on let me see something here
don't be no rainbow read me [__]
50 million
that's one of the best segments of all
time you know he still gets asked about
it and he's like I'm still to this damn
age people ask me about that he really
did not think that that was going to be
a problem too with LeVar Burton
hey hey Marsh you want you asked me what
do we need to do to make good to kill
him you want to know what we need to do
to make 50 million dollars I got you fam
laughs
it sounds like the old uh Diamond Dallas
Page entrance name like yeah Jimmy Hart
ripoff
[Music]
do you want to know the worst thing
about this
to try you make
emails video and not the Nirvana like
you ready to laugh
first off can I say there's a rule here
that probably every everybody's making
music parody should do if Weird Al's
already parodied that song you do not
make another parody of that song right
like he's the guy right like are you
gonna make another Beat It parody eat it
already exist so Crowder's doing smells
like two spirit which obviously weird
out the parody of his song who likes
this though man Boomers
I eat this [__] up it's their favorite
wouldn't this be like a boner killer for
you if you like met a chick and she put
this on it was like you gotta see this
this is so fun how hard is she like yeah
I mean I've got to give me a level
eight or below
you probably would still be like that
can nah but if they're like a nine or a
ten I get I mean there's there's things
women will confess to you if they're a
10 and you're like that's fine I'm gonna
pretend I didn't hear you pretend you're
into the Crowder you move into kisser
and then while you're kissing her reach
over and turn off the Crowder she okay
so she's she looks like like Chrisley's
daughter what's her name uh the Savannah
Crystal she looks Savannah Chrisley okay
so that's a 910 so we have nine ten now
okay okay
you get in a car with her here's what
we're doing you get in a car with her
guaranteed [__] but you have to get
through this one hour car one hour car
ride with her okay
how many Crowder parody songs would you
listen to before you go I don't care how
hot you are I will not [__] you how slow
she driving an hour ten hours an hour
for pictures and locals yes yes oh hold
on hold on hold on hold on
that's fair let's make it fair let's
post the pictures up that's a good call
okay can I can I make it a point then
yeah if it's a chick that looks like
Savannah Chrisley I couldn't make it if
it's Savannah Chrisley it's Savannah
Chrisley okay I could probably make the
hour just for the story okay you saw so
but okay but because that's a lifetime
that's a lot that's a lifetime of
bragging that I [__] Savannah Chris bro
I would make new parodies with her we'd
make up some I'd suck Crowder's dick to
[__] this broad
he would lit you
and then guess what guess what you
wouldn't [__] this broad something's got
to get the [__] off you suck Stephen
Crowder's dick oh my God I was kidding
about the parodies so she's like [__] of
all people she goes sorry my dad told me
to never get with [__] wait a minute
your dad said that you sure you're okay
like your dad dad
the gay guy from TV
all right
but you know what they say I'm always
attracted to people that are like my dad
you sucked a dick and I'm kind of
digging it
huh
[Music]
what he's fighting for you but again
this feels that sounds like someone
that's not fighting like hell this feels
like
like Crowder is like one of those things
where it's like you you it's huge his
numbers are huge of course but I don't
know anybody that actually likes him in
my life everybody in the Villages
[__] glassed
huh
[Music]
million dollars